[Musique]
audition publique avec sébastien chenu
député du nord et porte parole du
rassemblement national bonsoir bonsoir
première question mais ouais marine le
pen marine le pen a été retenu par un
certain nombre d'obligations ce qui fait
que je suis ça triste et modeste
doublure j'espère vous consoler avec mes
réponses de l'absence de marine le pen
vous savez que lé ans répond aux
invitations des médias avec toujours la
même constance entre il a annulé venus c
le matin même il se décommande ce n'est
pas dans ses habitudes elle avait une
très bonne raison je ne dévoilerai pas
évidemment ici mais non non non non mais
j'espère m'acquitter de au mieux de ma
tâche en ayant accepté de répondre du
coup à votre invitation et en essayant
de celui qu'elle est la bienvenue à
mission publique
voilà on entend donc c'est une
contrariété vous êtes là on va vous
écouter vous mélangez bien évidemment
pendant une heure s'est arrêté pour nous
téléspectateurs et puis pour tout nous
et qu'il nous en excuses
les chaînes parlementaires bien sûr le
figaro l afp
vous l'avez déjà noter donc yves thréard
qui est ici présents qui représente le
figaro à ses côtés anne renault pour la
sp avant tout à l'heure au rayonnement
de chimie et bruits de bouche et de
public sénat et de lcp et entre les deux
deux parlementaires comme chaque semaine
il y aura tout à l'heure le député la
république en marche bruno keitel et le
sénateur et l'ère alain monsieur jean
bizet voilà donc la mobilisation des
gilets jaunes a baissé de moitié on l'a
vu samedi sébastien chenu à ce que vous
y voyez les faits du mea culpa et puis
des mesures sociales du chef de l'état
je crois pas je crois qu'il ya des
raisons circonstancielles
je crois que les dernières violences à
paris au plus tôt ont pu effrayer un
certain nombre de gilets jaunes sincère
qui venaient manifester qu'ils avaient
plus envie de se retrouver pris par la
racaille je crois que la proche des
fêtes de noël amène les gens à voir
également des préoccupations
personnelles qui les rattrape et je
crois que les problèmes ne sont pas
traités au fond donc on risque de voir
ressurgir peut-être sous d'autres formes
d'ailleurs les gilets jaunes ou d'autres
d'ailleurs
en bas on peut ne les fait pas un acte
aussi cela samedi prochain mais nous
n'avons jamais foulé en dessous sont les
revendications des gilets jaunes à mais
nous nous sommes toujours gardé de
donner des instructions le contester ou
de ne pas aller manifester
non le compte n'y est pas et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les français qui ont
écouté le président macron les 23
millions de français ont été victimes
d'une véritable chèque news en dira non
non c'est un bon force à des milliards
d'euros pour les obliger à venir fait
une fake news now je considère que
l'idée de dire aux français qu'ils vont
mieux gagner leur vie par le travail
c'est ce qu' edouard philippe d'ailleurs
disait ce matin dans les colonnes de la
presse est une fête nous car évidemment
la prime d'activité qui est lié un
certain nombre de critères de
contraintes
eh bien ce n'est pas une c'est une
prestation sociale ce n'est pas la
valorisation du travail donc déjà je
pense que déjà je pense alors on y
viendra
mais j'ai déjà je pense que sur les
fameux 100 euros
lié entre l'appui de l'activité et puis
la hausse mécanique du smic eh bien je
pense que le gouvernement a commencé à
mentir aux français sur et puisque nous
parlons des airs mesures du gouvernement
et sur les heures supplémentaires
permettez moi de dire et moi je voudrais
je voterai cette mesure parce que nous
nous l'avons proposé nous nous l'avons
proposé mais les députés en marche ont
voté contre
donc avec un plaisir non feint je
voterai cette mesure et je verrai mes
collègues de la république en marche la
voter enfin donc évidemment dans ce
brouhaha dans ce dans ce brouillard et
cetera gouvernementales les choses qui
vont dans le sens de l'intérêt des
français
nous l'évoquerons mais je pense que la
déception sera ouvert dès voté toutes
les causes du rhin nous nous voterons
les mesures qui améliorent la vie des
français n'y a pas à dire il n'y a pas
de raison de ne pas aller voter c'est à
dire la csg pour la retraite de moins de
1000 euros il ya pas de raison de pal à
voter mais nous nous aurions préféré la
réindexation des retraites sur le coût
de la vie les heures supplémentaires
nous l'avons proposé donc nous sommes
cohérents nous allons la voter ce sont
les députés en marche qui souffre d'une
incohérence chronique et puis le la
suite le smic nous allons évidemment le
voter mais non mon avion nous nous avons
fait une autre proposition qui je crois
est est plus importante était plus
ambitieux c'était celle d'augmenter les
petits salaires et les petites retraites
de 200 euros en finance en cela par une
taxe à 3% sur les importations donc on
était beaucoup plus ambitieux mais la
première fortune allez vous savez que
l'impôt sur la fortune nous à nous
n'avons pas voté la fin de l'impôt sur
la fortune car nous nous sommes
favorables à l'impôt sur la fortune
à partir du moment où on en sort la
résidence principale en jeu note quand
même que vous allez voter toutes ces
mesures sociales en les voyant qu'ils se
sont défaits gagne ou non c'est à dire
qu'en réalité tout le monde a bien
compris que le président de la
république avait pris ici et là des
mesures
lié à l'actualité pour empêcher que de
se retrouver coincé au moment de la fin
de l'année dans une situation qui
n'arrivait plus à maîtriser pour calmer
les gilet jaune mais il ne résout rien
sur le fond est là et je devrais être
content quand même c'est qu'il laisse
filer les déficits vous avez toujours
dit que la règle du pacte de stabilité
3% de déficit par rapport au pib était
une règle absurde
m6 ne s'agit pas d'être content il
s'agit de démontrer que la politique que
celui-là nous mettrons le suivi de mâcon
est un non sens et en fait ils le
démontrent lui-même il ya trois crises
dans cette crise il y à une crise du
pouvoir d'achat j'allais dire la
répartition sociale des richesses il ya
une crise sur l'aménagement du
territoire n'a aucune réponse c'est à
dire la répartition spatiale des
richesses et puis il ya une crise de
représentativité et là aussi on aurait
beaucoup à dire alors jusqu'au plus dure
est ce qu'on veut dire parce que la
question du débat maintenant est posée
mais si ça en votant ces mesures est ce
que vous ne prenez pas le chemin du
dialogue que demande émane macron mais
nous avons toujours été dans une
position dialogue je vous ai donné un
exemple de mesures que nous avons
proposé et quand nous proposions les
heures supplémentaires le fameux
travailler plus pour gagner plus que
nous l'avons proposé au parlement ce
sont les députés en marche qui ont
refusé de le voter
ils reviennent penaud nous proposer la
mesure que nous avons proposé alors
c'est assez savoureux mais au delà de ça
c'est inquiétant ça montre que ce
gouvernement ce sont des amateurs et qui
n'ont aucune vision à long terme
est ce que vous êtes inquiet de voir que
le sujet de l'amérique de l'immigration
qui devaient figurer justement dans ce
débat national qui va s'ouvrir à ces
jours ci a été un peu marginalisé à la
demande de certains qui ont dit mais
c'est pas le sujet les gilet jaune n'ont
jamais parlé d'immigration écouté le
débat national
s'il ya des sujets on peut pas aborder
dans ce débat national or c'est plus un
débat le président de la république dit
devant 23 millions de français nous
parlerons des migrations quelques jours
après premier ministre dit finalement
nous en parlerons pas que veulent faire
ces gens veulent faire ces gens avec les
français soleil on a déjà parlé de
l'identitaire dans ce mouvement des
gilets jaunes d'après vous un problème
identitaire
certes idée française l'identité je
crois que les gilets jaunes ont tout à
fait perçu qu'il y avait dans notre pays
des inégalités qui était dû au fait que
nous poursuivions depuis longtemps que
celles et ceux qui sont au pouvoir
depuis trente ans pour suivre une
politique immigrationniste qui crée des
déséquilibres dans notre pays je crois
qu'ils ont bien identifié comme ça les
gens sont plein de bon sens cette fois
sur la table mais bien sûr il faut le
mettre sur la table il ya quelque chose
qui va beaucoup faire le permettez moi
juste cela qui m'a beaucoup peut
interroger cette semaine le plafonnement
des indemnités prix d'aumale a été
retoquée au motif qu'il n'était pas
conforme au droit international
et on nous a dit pendant des semaines et
des semaines qu'on avait face à nous des
as de l'économie qu'on avait des gens
incroyables
alors nous a vendu un nouveau monde et
c'est au mépris d'ailleurs des discours
de l'opposition vous parliez de dialogue
madame nous nous l'avions dit à l'époque
sur le plafonnement des indemnités
prud'homale que ça ne pouvait pas passer
que ça ne pouvait pas fonctionner et que
c'était injuste et bien aujourd'hui
vient de se faire retoquer ça c'était
une demande très forte vous le savez des
patrons et notamment des des patrons des
petites entreprises est là non mais ça
ne pouvait pas fonctionner et ça ne
fonctionne pas le brevet je sais que
c'est non je sorte de la réforme sur le
droit du travail soit effectivement
contestant joue parce qu'elle est
injuste mais moi ceux qui derrière me
préoccupe c'est que ce gouvernement ne
sait pas où il emmène la france ce sont
des bricoleurs ce sont des amateurs et
il y à lui si il ya eu tromperie sur la
marchandise
alors question de l'aivp à en entendre
alors annoncé un dialogue est ce qu'il
faut évacuer les ronds points
mais ce sont les gilets jaunes qui
prendront la décision de leur mouvement
de ce qu'ils veulent faire
mais alors la zambie le gouvernement non
pas des noms il ya des interventions et
des évacuations
non non vous savez au début du concret
au début du conflit la france a subi on
s'en va dire non aux normes et non on
les soutient depuis le début on soutient
leurs revendications j'allais dire je
suis con les soutenait même avant que
les gilets jaunes existe puisque
évidemment dans leurs revendications
font évacuer les rangs de -10 à mon ami
certains moments il y à ce moment 10 aux
partis politiques ne vous en mêlez pas
maintenant on dit aux partis politiques
de mes livres doute de tout cela est dit
ce qu'il faut faire
les gilets jaunes prendront leurs
responsabilités ils les ont prises
samedi
vous avez remarqué que les gilet jaune
reste shalit et sa demande intérieure
ouvre ses responsabilités qu'ils y
soient email
est-ce que c'est son sourire et qu'il
est dans son coin sa mission juste je
considère depuis le début que christophe
castaner est un incapable qu'il a été
incapable de gérer les manifestations et
en particulier allez les
les casseurs la racaille etc y compris
en laissant ouvert d'ailleurs toutes les
stations de métro de l'est parisien du
nord parisien laissant une certaine
faune arrivée sur les champs elysées
alors qu'il fermait l'état est trop oui
oui mais enfin les stations de métro des
champs elysées tous a été bouclé alors
on a vu que certaines stations parle de
l'été par le dal va s'engager vous allez
y participer en qualité d'élue il ya des
maires du rassemblement national qui
vont y participer
il ya une mesure là qui vient sur la
table c'est le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne pour ou contre
alors j'y suis favorable d'abord parce
que vous savez nous avons une cohérence
nous avons défendu marine le pen défend
ce référendum depuis 2012
donc on n'a pas aujourd'hui dire le
contraire mais moi je veux dire deux
choses d'abord ce référendum il doit
être assortie de la proportionnelle pour
une raison j'allais dire chenal à quel
niveau
enfin la proportionnelle à partir de 5%
pour être représentés à l'assemblée
nationale et avec une prime majoritaire
si on veut permettre un équilibre et une
stabilité pour la majorité qui en sort
moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il y ait
d'un côté dans l'arsenal de notre pays
la proportionnelle et le référendum par
titre complément intégral mais je
voulais 10 intègre à la partie avec un
seuil de 5%
quand on fait plus de 5% doit pouvoir
être représentés venus intègrent armée
nationale
bien sûr pourquoi parce que la
proportionnelle tecan vous représentez
21% des français si je prends le score
de marine le pen au premier tour et que
vous avez 1 % des députés
personne ne viendra vous dire
aujourd'hui que cette situation est
juste le malaise est en forme à la
réalité bien entendu et la vie crise de
la représentativité est d'importance et
le référendum
moi j'y suis favorable nous l'avons
toujours été il ya des pays qui
le pratiquent déjà depuis longtemps je
pense d'ailleurs à la suisse qui a fait
d'ailleurs un référendum sur
l'immigration
ce qui lui a permis de faire entrer dans
sa législation la préférence nationale
et vous en suisse donc moi je suis
favorable sur la bien sûr mais à partir
du moment où on respecte le résultat du
référendum
j'ai le souvenir qu'en 2005 référendum
en france le résultat n'a pas été
respecté et puis à partir du moment où
il n'y a pas de sujet tabou
d'accord et si votre est ce que
justement cette très si ses
revendications des gilet jaune sont très
proches des vôtres est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à en accueillir sur votre liste
aux européennes
là aussi on doit pas s'interdire quoi
que ce soit mais moi je ne veux pas que
ce soit une en contact avec quelques
arbres oui bien sûr j'ai rencontré un
certain danger les jeunes d'abord dans
mon département je rencontre mais j'ai
rencontrés ils seraient susceptibles de
venir soit la semaine dernière j'ai
rencontré je ne lis pas proposé de venir
elle ne m'a pas proposé quoi que ce soit
que j'ai rencontré madame e jacqueline
roux à la jackass j'ai rencontré
monsieur cauchy sur des plateaux de
télévision
on discute d'autres le gilet jaune aussi
n'y a aucun problème à cela mais je ne
veux pas qu'on accueille des gens pour
des raisons j'allais dire de nos gadgets
mois ci nous accueillons des gens qui
sont gilet jaune
ces sont des gens qui ont des
convictions qui partagent très épuisant
fasse un peu d'ombré
quand même parce qu'il ya un âge qui
manquent le coche s'ils ont leur livret
jeune à rhodia de rassemblement national
et bien et beaucoup moins fort je veux
dire deux choses
histoire moi je ne doute jamais ce que
fait le peuple conquérant 2 celles et
ceux qui essayeraient de manipuler les
gilet jaune en montant des listes qui
seraient des fausses listes de gilets
jaunes soutenu en sous-main à part des
pouvoirs qui se diraient conclu à tayrac
en platine aux non mais écoutez on peut
on peut très bien on n'est pas des
enfants de choeur on peut très bien le
poser ça sur la table
eh bien je pense que ça leur reviendra
en boomerang il avait un talent il faut
s'arrêter sur accusation l'accusé sous
jacente a justement c'était ma question
je vous regarde vous soupçonnez
entraînements
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui ceux qui
se diraient quelque part des petites
manipulations que ça ressemble à ceux
qui manipulent les modes de scrutin
avant les élections qui se disent
ouhlala en faisant monter une liste le
gilet jaune on va peut-être affaiblir le
rassemblement national la france a
soumis un excellent terreau à des gens
qui auraient intérêt à vous monsieur
macro qu'il peut être intérêt donc je ne
sais pas mais je dis oui mais bien la
mena je mets en garde à l'effet
boomerang
je mets en bagarre d'alban comme cet
effet existe lorsque ce qui
tripatouillent les scrutins les
élections passent autant qu'elle
sanctionnait vous avez je ne crois pas
que nous ayons face à nous des enfants
de choeur nous ne sommes pas non plus et
nous considérons qu'il vaut mieux des
chanteurs des danseurs passion non nous
dire qu'il y aurait la main invisible de
l'énergie en action pour monter une
liste des jurés jeu il faut vous
affaiblir et pour effectivement
favoriser la nudité des calculs
électoraux d'avoir réparé à ce genre de
scénario est que nous ne leur ou dreux
doutons pas du tout allez on va vous
dire effectivement alors la complotite
contre le faux vous avez été écoeurée
par le complice mais qu'on a vu surgir
après le terrible attentat islamiste de
strasbourg
j'ai trouvé ça indécent indécent et
lamentable à voyez vous mais le
complotisme vous savez il suffit de se
brancher devant votre ordinateur pour
découvrir des tas de complot par exemple
j'ai beaucoup lu que la presse avait
soutenu emmanuel macron et avait fait
l'élection de lionel macron complotisme
c'est beaucoup de gens qui on pensait
que les médias ont soutenu emmanuel
macron et que grâce à léo grâce aux
médias il a pu devenir prison la
physique naissent du couple autistes
chose qu'une part de réalité la
grisaille et sondages notamment dans le
genre a lieu dimanche ir qui vous sont
assez favorables en prévision des
élections européennes ses intentions de
vote
vous êtes à 26 27% le président de la
république se tient somme toute assez
bien en dépit de son impopularité son
impopularité profonde mais en attention
de vote
il est en deuxième position pas
président de la république une liste en
marche
oui parce que je croise inspire quoi ce
que je crois que c'est la redéfinition
de notre système politique avec deux
offres très différentes d'un côté une
offre qui assume son côté mondialistes
les curistes et ultralibéral et puis de
l'autre côté 16 à ceux qui parlent de la
nation
qui pense que l'état encore une place
que la france encore son mot à dire dans
le concert des nations que les ont
éliminés
je crois que les autres le problème
c'est qu'il ne pense plus rien que
pensent les républicains que pensent les
socialistes à subissent les pinceaux
mille la proximité sont à la marge
l'extrême gauche reste un phénomène qui
ne peut pas je crois aujourd'hui réunir
autour d'elle de par ses positions
notamment sur l'immigration ne peut pas
ne peut pas à réunir autour d'elle des
courants de pensée si différents que
cela donc je crois qu'il ya de grands
deux grandes familles politiques qui
sont en train de se structurer même de
ce peut être de se restructurer autour
de deux grands pôles et ce face à face
qu emmanuel macron avait lui-même appelé
de ses voeux et qu'il avait lui-même
installé eh bien oui il est en train de
prendre corps et les réformes vous
pensez qu elles sont en marche est ce
que emmanuel macron à surmonter la crise
et va mettre en place ces réformes je
crois que emmanuel macron aura beaucoup
de mal il faut dire a passé l'ensemble
de ces réformes demain tels qu'il les
avait imaginées
s'il pense attaqué une réforme
constitutionnelle avec 15% de
proportionnelle dans cette réforme il se
met le doigt dans l'oeil
s'il pense que les gilets jaunes ne vont
pas comprendre ce qu'il est en train de
faire il se met le doigt dans l'oeil
donc je pense que voilà emmanuel macron
n'a pas voulu reculer sur ce qui fait sa
matrice politique et edouard philippe
nous a dit ce matin il n'y a pas de
tournant social c'est bien ce qu'on lui
reproche d'ailleurs le cas n'y a pas de
tournant sauvegarder mais là il ya un
changement de méthode
oui mais ça c'est pour habiller on a
bien compris que derrière et mon imac
rond était toujours l'enfant de
l'ultralibéralisme vous habitez quand
même peut-être un accent avec bonheur je
ne sais pas il a confessé effectivement
avoir commis des erreurs lui il fallait
exécutif dans la gestion de cette crise
oui bah c'est moins confuse et parce
qu'il ya des lois qu'on cible et il est
en décalage absolue avec ce qui se passe
partout en europe il est très isolé son
discours ne porte pas les françaises et
les tests oui les français le déteste
aujourd'hui c'est alors qu'est ce qui a
mal entendu
emmanuel macron crois qu'il a été élu
pour mener pour mettre en place son
programme il a été l'un parce qu'avoir
ben oui ou non il est élu parce qu'à un
moment on a fait
on est en des partis politiques à la
ramasse barrage à marine le pen il a mac
applique ce ne sont que son programme ne
représente 20 6 et marc en défense il
aurait dû changer de gouvernement et
faire comme certains le disent jean
christophe cambadélis et d'autres faire
un gouvernement de concorde nationale
non mais moi je crois pas du tout à ces
bidouillages je veux dire moi je pense
que emmanuel macron on aurait dû
comprendre que la politique qu'il mène
les français n'en veulent pas parce
qu'elle ne produit pas de résultats et
qu'elle est injuste et vous savez une
politique qui est injuste qui tape les
plus faibles et qui ne produit pas de
résultats
vous ne pouvez pas rassembler le peuple
de france autour de vous avec ça vous
pouvez composer les gens les uns aux
autres savons nous avait dit avec marine
le pen ce sera le cas au combien de fois
ai-je entendu ça sur les plateaux
télévisés pendant la campagne
présidentielle
ah oui mais avec marine le pen ce sera
le chaos on en est où là aujourd'hui
il a mis la france dans quel état y
mendel macron ya une sorte de nouvel
esprit de dégagisme en fête avec ses
gilet jaune est ce que vous ne pensez
pas en faire partie c'est de faire
partie des gens qui doivent être dégagés
puisque donc il ya les privilèges des
élus sont dénoncés qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous non parce que moi je crois
qu'effectivement les gens veulent
dégager ceux qui depuis trente ans ont
responsabilités mène les mêmes
politiques alternativement qu'ils soient
de droite ou de gauche
emmanuel macron voulait faire une
politique avec la droite avec la gauche
il fait la pire des politiques avec le
pire de la droite le pire de la gauche
donc le quinquennat ne va pas reprendre
son cours normal à vous c'est écoutez je
crois qu'à ce qu'elle quitte à finir son
mandat
dax a fini à ce moment là les
institutions lui permettent moi j'aurais
souhaité qu'il aille plutôt à des
élections législatives anticipées
merci c'est la fin de cette première
partie merci tous les deux nous allons
donc maintenant accueillir les deux
parlementaires que je vous annonçais
tout à l'heure
les voici les voici donc député la
public en marche de leur bloquer tel
bonsoir et puis le sénateur jean bizet
sénateur de la manche et président de la
commission des affaires européennes car
c'est votre grand engagement n'est ce
pas l'europe il en sera question lors de
ces échanges que vous allez maintenant à
voir je pose quand même une question
d'un internaute du figaro qui vous
demande monsieur chenu combien il y aura
t'il d'ouvriers de paysans et de
retraités modestes en position éligible
sur votre liste vous européenne n'en
parlent pas y ait des gilets jaunes mais
voilà les oreillers il y a toujours eue
nous sommes le parti qui présente le
plus d'ouvriers d'employés de paysans de
retraités d'étudiants et qu'il est fait
élire
vous pouvez regarder par exemple dans
les régions nous sommes le parti
politique qui avait très bien lire
aujourd'hui on n'a pas fait la liste
alors je peux en dire comme il y en
avait un il y aura effectivement des
gens de qui ont-ils gagnent leur vie qui
sont la société civile et qui seront sur
nos listes
il y en a toujours eu la gorge enquête
elle d'abord un mot sur ce qui m'amuse
qui es tu pour doc est elle un mois déjà
sur ce qui vous est arrivé ce week-end
puisque vous avez vu des gilets jaunes
arrivé et il ya eu devant votre
habitation
des coups de feu oui six coups de fusil
à pompe et quelques minutes après une
quarantaine de personnes sont arrivées
avec l'intention non dissimulée dans
l'entrée dans mon domicile
voilà les gendarmes sont arrivés ensuite
et les choses se sont déroulées dans un
climat de tensions non dissimulé pendant
un peu plus d'une demi-heure progrès en
lors dans l'ordre ensuite préjugés de
quelques fumigènes y compris sur moi
même
etc etc qu'est ce que vous attendez des
responsables politiques qui aujourd'hui
soutiennent toujours les gilets jaunes
et leur demande de poursuivre leur
action
am je me garderai bien de poser mon
collègue chenu responsable du
comportement du groupe
plusieurs dizaines de personnes qui
était depuis trois heures à un
rond-point manifestement accompagnés par
les conséquences de la consommation de
diverses substances et
dans une logique qui était celle voilà
de rentrer à la maison familiale et
autres maintenant il faut que tout ça se
calme mais il faut que les pouvoirs
publics aussi met en place ce débat et
que les choses soient organisées de
manière à ce que chacun y trouve sa
place
premières questions à notre invité sur
peut-être la conception qu'il a de la
citoyenneté car c'est un sujet qui vous
est cher oui non j'aurais voulu savoir
effectivement monsieur chenu quelle est
votre conception de la citoyenneté vous
parlez souvent de mondialisme de deux
influences étrangères sur notre pays
qu'est-ce qu'être français
et quels sont selon vous ce qu'on
devrait avoir comme notion de devoir est
de droit qui s'attacherait citoyenneté
française
je crois que la conception de la
citoyenneté qui est la mienne celle de
défendre des idées et non pas des
intérêts et c'est je crois souvent ce
qui nous a séparés la majorité en marche
et un certain nombre de députés
d'opposition
nous avons compris rapidement que cette
majorité si vous me permettrez j'en
donnerai un exemple défendent des
intérêts qu'il n'était pas l'intérêt
général or moi lorsque je me suis engagé
en politique et je les fais il ya déjà
bien longtemps peut-être comme vous
d'ailleurs et nous nous sommes croisés
dans des vies précédentes préfet
d'ailleurs eh bien je les fais pour
défendre des idées et cette majorité je
la vois défendre des intérêts et c'est
je crois vraiment ce qui fait la
différence
je visais vous même vous avez une
expérience plusieurs expériences même
avec les gilet jaune mais à des
ronds-points vous êtes peut-être ici un
témoignage apporté on va écouter
effectivement des expériences pas tout à
fait agréable et qui m'ont fait penser
si vous voulez que tant que nous
n'aurons pas réglé ces zones de non
droit qui vit en france que ce soit
notre dame des landes ou bien quelques
zones de banlieue nous aurons si je puis
dire des des phénomènes de ce type et je
ne comprends pas comment le
rassemblement national puis soutenir ce
type de démarche
ça le monsieur le président je ne
mettrai pas sur 1
sur la même ligne l'occupation par les
gilets jaunes des ronds-points ou nous
dit vous ne comprenez pas que nous les
soutenions et les racailles de banlieue
où les gens qui portent atteinte à la
vie et aux biens de nos compatriotes
puis vous monsieur je ne le ferai pas et
je trouve très dangereux de le faire
surtout lorsque comme vous on a fait
partie d'une majorité qui a été aux
affaires et qui n'a pas résolu ces
problèmes là je me garderai bien de
mettre sur la même ligne des français
qui se lèvent le matin pour aller
travailler et qui viennent sur des ronds
points et je condamne parfaitement les
violences que mon collègue qui est elle
a dû subir et supporter à niamey mais
non mais je ne banalise pas vous savez
j'ai longtemps entendu une petite phrase
lors des attentats qui était pas d'
amalgame
et bien moi je n'ai mal gamme pas les
français qui se lèvent avec un gilet
jaune et qui vont manifester
et puis des voyous qui se comporte mal
parce que je crois qu'ils sont d'abord
minoritaires et je crois aussi que il y
a des problèmes vous l'avais dit dans
les banlieues il ya des problèmes dans
des cités il y a des problèmes de non
respect de la loi partout dans ce pays
mais qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
prendre les gilet jaune comme exutoire
et dire regardez les gilets jaunes sont
des sont des voyous ce n'est pas
vrai monsieur jean bizet voulait
peut-être répondre ça vous en parlez moi
vous avez entendu ce matin
non non mais mettre sur le même plan des
plus faciles gilet jaune non mais c'est
extrêmement facile on sait j'en connais
j'en fréquente des gens qui souffrent
ceux qui souffrent ils sont pas là mais
pour croyez moi il sera là bas parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens d'être là
ils sont dans leur travail ils sont dans
leur exploitation ils sont dans leurs
petits commerces
ils ne sont pas précisément là non mais
je suis assez désole de voir si je puis
dire qu' il y ait précisément des partis
tels que le vote qu'ils ne soutenaient
parce que c'est pas comme ça si je puis
dire qu'on fera avancer le débat et
virer monsieur je vais vous dire je fais
je mets un point d'honneur à soutenir
les gens qui souffrent et qui en
travaillant n'arrivent pas à boucler
leurs fins de mois parce que je pense
qu'ils sont les premières victimes des
politiques qui ont été menées depuis
trente ans et que vous avez soutenu
monsieur ces gens là ils sont dans cette
situation là parce que vous avez été au
pouvoir et parce que vous avez voté et
soutenu un certain nombre de choses qui
les mène dans cette situation la force
de la frontière nationale usées vous
êtes un parti qui revendique l'ordre et
là vous vous souvenez les jeunes
amalgame pas défilée jour qui va lier
amouzou a tenté de l'ordre et là il ya
le désordre monsieur jeune amel gave pas
des hommes et des femmes qui occupent un
giratoire
je condamne celles et ceux qui peuvent
être majorés des voix lignes de banlieue
et au monsieur nous en a parlé mais on a
manqué néanmoins depuis trois semaines
ces quelques dizaines de personnes qui
ont voulu s'inviter chez moi vendredi
soir occupe un rond point je suis je
suis né là où j'habite
je les connais je suis allé les voir sur
le rond point la semaine dernière nous
avions échangé pendant plus de trois
heures et ces femmes et ces hommes je
les connais je suis élu depuis 1995
il imite politiquement et
essentiellement pour votre parti
politique je vous le reproche pas
entendons-nous bien je leur demande
juste de l'assumer et vous aussi parce
que il y en a mais oui c'est la réalité
du terrain et du concret ces femmes et
ces hommes sont des sympathisants du
rassemblement national pour l'essentiel
et quelques quelques uns france
insoumise c'est une forme d' amalgame
des deux extrêmes qui se rejoignent pour
dénoncer la politique mondialiste que
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure et ses
trente ou quarante années montrent même
remonté à 40 ans de politiques publiques
dont on pourrait comprendre ou expliquer
qu'elle justifie qu'aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de femmes et d'hommes ne
croient plus en la chose publique
parce que je vous ai interrogé sur la
citoyenneté j'attendis vous parle
justement de ces 50% de femmes et hommes
qui ne croient plus de voir venir voter
aujourd'hui plusieurs choses vous ne
pouvez pas diaboliser notre mouvement
politique jeudi venant de tels exemples
parce que voyez vous moi je pourrais
parler de démontrer ce que je pourrais
par les députés de la république en
marche qui se sont très mal comporté et
qui sont pourtant les représentants du
peuple qui se sent très mal comporté
dans l'actualité qui nous l'a montré et
je pars égard et pour vous et pour votre
groupe
je ne citerai ni leur nom ni leur
comportement mais l'actualité et la
capacité à chacun d'aller le vérifier
sur internet nous rappellera qu'il était
en maths l'articulation et qui se sont
non mais je vous crache et le breton qui
se sont mal comportés sur wii pourquoi
je dis que vous défendez non pas des
idées mais des intérêts et j'allais vous
donner deux exemples
la première c'est je crois la façon dont
les députés en marche on était entre
guillemets castet sur cv et bien oui ou
pour moi la politique et ça rebondit sur
ce que je disais tout à l'heure dur at
il des ouvriers sur vos listes on ne
capte pas les gens sur cv ce n'est pas
la star ac c'est pareil on a eu on a eu
des dizaines d'exemples de rythme et
j'ai le souvenir d'un député du pas de
calais nous disant je n'ai même pas une
commission d'investiture j'ai envoyé mon
cv
on m'a appelé au téléphone je suis
devenu député un mois après donc voyez
cette façon cette approche qui ne qui
n'est en aucun cas une approche
méritocrate je ne dis pas que c'est
votre cas particulier mais ne correspond
pas en tous les cas voilà le deuxième
reproche dans la défense des des
intérêts et non pas des idées j'ai vu la
république en marche au service de lobby
je les ai vus lors du débat sur
l'agriculture et la protection animale
voyez vous lorsque nous avons demandé et
ce n'est pas un député rassemblement
national qui a demandé c'était un député
non-inscrit de gauche que par exemple la
protection animale soit regarder avec
plus d'attention qu'on puisse créer
peut-être quelques normes qui
empêcherait conte et pardonnez moi pour
l'aspect plus valorisants d'écraser des
poussins de transporter des poules dans
mauvaise condition eh bien je pensais
que ça ferait l'unanimité à l'assemblée
non on nous avons compris les débiteurs
marche ont empêché que ces mesures
soient prises parce que derrière il y
avait des lobbys de l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui ont dit que
j'attendais que monsieur chine par
exemple qui concerne les françaises et
les français me parle d' exemple qui
concerne les poulets dénonçons on a
chacun nos on a chacun avançait de la
république en marche que d'être
méprisant pendant les arrivées des
adversaires je suis pas de ce fait le
show en bois juste laisser terminer
monsieur qu'après vous pourrez réagir
aux propos de gilles legendre ce matin
alors je vous dis cela monsieur venu
parce que je pense que c'est pas bien de
ramener l'action de 18 mois d'une
majorité quelle qu'elle soit à un
exemple qui porte sur les poulets les
finances et la défense c'est un peu ça
ne peut pas caractérisée et symbolisé à
elle seule l'ensemble de la politique
menée depuis 18 mois évidemment parler
de tout ce que vous avez fait contre les
français qui souffrent la baisse des
appels etc
mais je vous ai volontairement donner un
exemple qui est peu connue qui montrent
que vous êtes la seule
gilles legendre ce matin à votre
président de groupe qui dit qu'en fait
vous avez péché par trop d'intelligences
et trop de subtilité voyez-vous ce
marqueur de mépris vis-à-vis de vos
adversaires politiques est vraiment
devenu l'emblème de la république en
marche et vous venez encore de le
démontrer c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
n'est pas d'accord vous êtes vous
ridiculisez vous essayez de ridiculiser
vos adversaires on en leur dénigrant le
fait d'avoir des arguments qui ne vous
intéressent satisfaction tout ça est
donc allé à paris et l'europe l'europe
l'europe l'europe l'euro l'euro
également et puis le break site alors un
jean bizet vous avez des questions à
poser des précisions a demandé au
représentant du rassemblement national
absolument je ne vous entend plus enfin
par vous même monsieur chez lui mais
votre parti politique
vous ne parlez plus de la sortie de
l'euro vous ne parlez plus de la sortie
de l'union européenne vous ne parlez
plus si je puis dire où nous ne parlait
pas de break site vous ne parlez pas des
du dossier sur l'extraterritorialité des
lois américaines sur les investissements
directs étrangers
on ne vous entend plus j'aimerais
comprendre alors je pense que d'abord
vous ne prêtez peut-être pas attention à
notre discours
mais puisque je suis invité ici je vais
pouvoir en parler et surtout la campagne
qui s'ouvre va pouvoir nous permettre de
parler d'europe et de parler de ce que
je crois être certaine forme de gâchis
nous sommes européens par construction
par civilisation par entité personnel
nous sommes européens
mais oui nous combattons ce système
politique parce que nous considérons
qu'il est en échec
on ne combat pas pour le plaisir nous
considérons que ce système politique est
en échec mais il ne vous a pas échappé
que la situation un petit peu évolué ces
dernières années
l'arrivée d'un certain nombre de nos
amis au pouvoir dans des coalitions je
pense à l'autriche par exemple où je
pense à l'italie avec matteo salvini
change un peu la donne en échange
engrais aussi oui pareillement change un
peu la donne et je crois nous permet
d'envisager demain une construction de
l'union européenne qu'ils soient très
différentes
donc non plus d'en sortir avec fracas
mais peut-être de l'intérieur pour la
première fois de la changer parce que
voyez vous si nous envoyons une majorité
où un grand nombre
deux députés eurosceptiques euros
combatif souverainiste appelez les comme
vous souhaitez mais qui ne sont pas
d'accord avec ce chemin européen alors
tout changer tout déjà possible si
demain le gouvernement italien je
termine mon propos monsieur président si
demain le gouvernement italien et le
gouvernement hongrois et ils le feront
désigne ou proposent des commissaires
européens de leur nationalité mais qui
répondent à la volonté politique de ces
états qui n'est plus la même volonté
politique la même sensibilité politique
que précédemment
alors les choses vont être
particulièrement différentes et alors
tout est possible je crois mais vous
avez vu vous êtes quand même vu que dans
cette construction européenne vous avez
souligné
vous avez parlé de l'italie vous voyez
très bien que entre les annonces faites
par le mouvement 5 étoiles qui était
absolument irréaliste
au bout de quelques 3 4 semaines eh bien
on en revient à beaucoup plus de
rationalité et que tout doucement le
projet de budget avec un déficit de 2,4
eh bien il va se terminer en dessous de
quand on n je dirais une monnaie commune
on a des responsabilités communes et
tout doucement on va revenir à quelque
chose de beaucoup plus cohérent vous
voyez très bien si je puis dire que la
construction européenne s'avère être
dans la conjoncture a dans ce monde
aussi turbulent et difficile la bonne
réponse à la situation
je n'ai pas le sentiment si vous voulez
je rêvais toujours eu cette approche et
ce n'est pas un échec si vous voulez
quand on voit un petit peu comment c'est
vrai que l'europe c'est le temps long
mais tout doucement regarde également le
travail de michel barnier qui a non
seulement réussi à maintenir l'unité des
27 mai qui a fait comprendre que nous
étions tous à 27
les copropriétaires du premier marché
économique mondiale alors c'est vrai ça
demande du temps ça demande beaucoup
d'explications mais je ne vous ai pas vu
jusqu'à maintenant dans un esprit dans
une posture constructif sur ce point là
monsieur le président on voulait ne m'en
voulez pas de vous dire que ça fait 30
ans que j'entends cette chanson trente
ans qu'on nous dise ça ira mieux demain
sur l'immigration ça ira mieux demain
sur la croissance la zone euro est la
plus faible du monde 15
ce raid deux millions sur millions de
l'immigration sont immigrés vous pouvez
y en avait que 250 à 300 sidéré que la
situation va bien français dans les
meetings sachant que je considère ça
s'est empiré
vous nous avez dit pendant trente ans il
faut plus d'europe et il y aura plus de
croissance
la zone euro est la plus faible en terme
de croissance
vous nous avez raconté beaucoup de
choses pendant trente ans en faisant il
faut plus d'europe et on s'aperçoit que
finalement les peuples partout se
réveille pour demander moins de cette
europe là ce qu'on veut ce sont des
nations qui coopèrent j'allais dire à la
carte de façon libre de façon
indépendante sans être obligé de
répondre à une sorte de diktat quasiment
carcérale qui fait que lorsque on n'est
pas lorsqu'on est prisonnier du dogme
des 3% de déficit
eh bien on sent des cartes alors du
gouvernement qui montre que ce dogme il
n'est pas tenable et juste sur matteo
salvini et les italiens pour pourrait
rebondir sur ce que vous avez dit les
italiens font de mémoire six milliards
d'économies et vont maintenir leur
grande dispositif leurs grandes
propositions de réforme aux italiens
matteo salvini à un taux de popularité
je crois dans le pays de 60 à 65 cents r
je crois considéré le plus vibrer les
rues tôt dans le tour je dirais
d'emprunt entre l'allemagne et l'italie
il ya aujourd'hui le spread est un
auteur de trois cents 300 points dès que
le monsieur selvini augmente un petit
peu ses prétentions d'augmenter le
budget le spread augmente si vous voulez
il ya énormément de cohérence en la
matière monsieur selvini a pris le
dessus ce du mouvement des cinq étoiles
c'est bien là le drame
mais à mon âge vous auriez préféré dans
l'air ce nom nina li lo très honnêtement
que c'est bien un problème dans la
tristesse et qui sont toujours séparés
même quand comme harvard vous êtes à
milanello que vous êtes alarmé par la
poussée des forces populistes en europe
oui bien sûr mais bien sûr parce que
tout est possible si vous voulez tout
est possible parce que pierre naud a
certes nos concitoyens sont fatigués
sont inquiets ils sont crispés ils
peuvent voter avec leurs pieds tout est
possible pour laquelle elle m'envoyait
un petit point un complément
du sénateur bizet le président on met
195 milliards d'euros pour équilibrer le
budget en emprunts le budget 2010 9 la
dette de la france ses 2900 euros par
seconde
quelle est votre conception de la dette
et caisses comment vous entendez un jour
éventuellement au pouvoir préserver
celle ci la dette
elle n'est pas de notre fait j'allais
dire nous en nous en hériteront n'est
pas que vous en êtes les artisans n'ont
alors que vous nous demandiez si on est
un petit peu aussi un engagement
chers collègues ont normalement vous
avez déjà essayé de respect pour ça je
veux dire que je les ai quittés
d'ailleurs c'est bien pour ça que je les
ai quittés parce que moi je n'ai pas
voulu continuer dans cette europe
libérale en battant m sur la dette nos
états sont endettés mais nous ce que
nous souhaitons vous savez c'est que les
banques c'est que ce qu'on appelle le
privacy et keesing pardonnez moi pour
cet anglais qui est un peu plus
approximatif et bien permettre de
reprendre la dette des pays qui sont
très endettés or pour cela il faut que
les banques centrales soient
indépendantes qu'elles puissent le faire
qu'elle puisse financer la dette de leur
pays
les banques centrales européennes ne
serait même un départ mais aujourd'hui
elles sont soumises elles sont soumises
à un diktat et je pense que c'est là le
problème
c'est une grande surprise d'apprendre ce
soir que les syndicats ne serait pas
allé en prison mario draghi est
absolument ravi après 7,1 à voir mais je
pense qu'il y en ait non seulement
l'artisan mais il est surtout pas la
victime de tout cela
non mais vous voyez bien si vous voulez
que je ne dis pas que l'europe est
parfaite
ce serait dommage de le dire non mais
j'ai l'honnêteté intellectuelle de le
dire mais aujourd'hui si vous voulez
c'est la meilleure construction est la
meilleure réponse possible dans ce monde
incertain le preneur le problème est que
le problème était en fait le bouc
émissaire si je ne fais pas les
problèmes c'est la supériorité du droit
européen sur le droit sur les droits
nationaux
bah oui c'est le problème alors quand on
réduit le champ de ce droit européen où
on fait en sorte que le droit national
prime sur le droit européen et sa
séquelle ça ne veut pas
si ça fonctionne et b6 fonctionner on
est dans un autre chemin
mais d'accord parce que vous nous
réunionnais alors résonner dans ce
schéma n'a fait de ce président parce
que vous raisonner dans ce schéma là qui
est un échec tant que vous raisonner sur
un schéma qui est en échec
évidemment les solutions que vous nous
proposez vous allez me dire ne peuvent
pas fonctionner parce que nous devrons
nous ne raisonnons pas les uns et les
autres dans le même schéma
nous nous vous proposons un autre schéma
vous nous proposez de continuer avec le
même
et moi je vous dis pas la supériorité du
droit européen sur le droit français et
jean scandale je quitte à un débat tout
à l'heure débat postérieure au conseil
européen avec la ministre madame loiseau
je lui ai proposé que sur une des
grandes politiques de l'europe qui est
la politique agricole commune
nous sortions je dirais d'un débat
purement budgétaire qui va être un petit
peu difficile pour dire attention il
faut qu'on change d'aproz en ce qui
concerne la proche agricole l approche
de l'autorité de la concurrence
ce qu'a fait l'autorité de la
concurrence il ya une cinquantaine
d'années n'est plus adapté à ce monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle si vous voulez je dis que nous
avons des améliorations et des
corrections à faire en europe
de toute façon proxy tout pop raxit il
nous faudra réenchanter l'europe
alors donc oui mais d'heure et des
réformes aussi alors on va changer de
sujet on a beaucoup parlé de l'europe un
monsieur qu'était vous vouliez
intervenir sur le plan pauvreté vous
avez une question précise toujours pas
eu sa réponse première non sur lequel
monsieur chez lui à dériver en parlant
des petits poussins sur la défense des
intérêts je vous ai dit moi je considère
que grosso modo les députés en mal à
défendre défendre des intérêts et non
pas des idées et nous le démontre dans
tous les choix budgétaires de ketele
voilà le plan pauvreté oui et puis la
location unique qui nous a été présentée
comme une perspective voilà le revenu
universel d'activité il reste une minute
un élément fondamental essentiel de mon
point de vue du plan pauvreté on change
complètement la logique aujourd'hui
plusieurs dizaines d'allocations
sociales diverses et variées c'est une
allocation unique un guichet unique
un parcours unique un profil unique et
un engagement demandé à chaque citoyenne
et citoyen qui bénéficierait de fonds
publics pour se réinsérer pour au contre
6 contre pourquoi j'y suis assez hostile
sur le principe pour peut-être deux
raisons de fond d'abord j'ai le
sentiment que les pays qui l'ont
il ya des pays du nord qu'ils ont
ébauché ça n'a pas été satisfaisant donc
je n'ai pas d'exemple me venant à
l'esprit immédiatement de succès de ceux
ci et puis je crois que par rapport à
l'idée qu'on se fait de la valeur
travail
eh bien je pense que ça peut entrer en
opposition avec l'idée de nous on peut
se faire de la valeur travail c'est à
dire cette allocation unique si je vous
comprends bien
elle serait donné à tout le monde y
compris les gens qui travaillent donc
non bon alors c'est tendance et alors
que voilà alors j'ai dire c'est alors
qu'un gars ciel serait votre parti et
des obligations obligation de s'engager
donc voyez se former à se réorienter et
à travailler
moi je vais vous dire je pense que non
c'est pas le revenu universel de venoix
quelque chose qui revient à que j'ai eu
je ne souffrais séduit d'emblée que
c'est par exemple qui fonctionne mais j'
avais entendu élections ni la motion il
va voter les mesures
les premières mesures les français
peuvent gratter quelque chose les
retraites mais pas moi justement non
j'espère que vous me dire partir du
moment les français pourraient gratter
garer choses peuvent de récupérer
l'argent je c'est parti comme ça je
conçois la désunion qui consiste juste à
gratter quelques biens selon la défense
vous avez voté contre
les heures supplémentaires et exalté et
là vous allez voter pour vous trouver sa
cohérence
d'ailleurs on a failli revenir tout à
l'heure voilà merci merci merci
messieurs les deux parlementaires
d'avoir accepté ce défi ce débat avec
monsieur chenu nous vous livrons merci
avec arme et en c'est l'heure de la
troisième partie d'auditions publiques
avec nos deux consoeurs qui arrive
[Musique]
le voilà merci merci messieurs mesdames
le temps qu'elle s'installe une question
d'un internaute du figaro qui a besoin
d'une précision sébastien chenu mais
alors pas trop développement quand même
quand même un good man 2
la france donc aujourd'hui en europe est
ce que vous êtes pour le fric si oui ou
non est ce que vous êtes pour ou non oui
ou non maintenant de l'euro alors soyons
là j'ai vu que je ne mange non je ne
suis pas pour le fric site
je souhaite qu'on change l'europe de
l'intérieur c'est l'accord fait ce sont
nos propositions et je souhaite par
contre que les britanniques l'on puisse
les accompagner
plutôt que si elle est bloquée je vois
une europe qui essaye de mettre qui
transforme le fric le mexique pardon en
chemin de croix pour les britanniques je
pense que c'est la faute de l'europe
c'est pas plutôt le jury qui ont émis
dans le pass l'europe doit respecter
l'union européenne doit respecter le
choix des britanniques d'accord ça ne
sert à rien de renvoyer on parle
éventuellement d'un nouveau vote vous
avez vu ce coup-ci leur programme alors
et l'euro on le garde à vue ni l'euro
très bien la présidentielle
l'euro c'est un outil on en débattra
appartement on aura retrouvé des
frontières et des lois alors avec nous
donc brigitte boucher et oriane mancini
bonsoir qui pose la première question
c'est aurillac on va parler terrorisme
monsieur l'attentât sur le marché noël à
strasbourg la semaine dernière a fait
cinq morts
marine le pen au pouvoir est ce que vous
pensez cet attentat aurait pu être évité
je pense que beaucoup d'attentats pour
être évité avec marine le pen au pouvoir
pour deux raisons la première c'est
qu'il ya une volonté de s'attaquer au
terrorisme islamiste je note d'abord que
le pouvoir en place a eu beaucoup de mal
à prononcer ce mot de terroristes
islamistes j'étais à l'assemblée lorsque
le premier ministre
on a parlé c'est dur de dire terroristes
islamistes et bien pourtant c'est
pourtant la réalité et la volonté n'y a
pas de racaille et a pas de moyens alors
si vous voulez ça fait un peu léger
parce que ils combien de mosquées
radicaliser ferme et quatre depuis un
certain nombre d'années depuis françois
hollande 4 combien d'associations
culturelles qui sont les faux nez d'un
islamisme rampant à qui on aurait coupé
des subventions combien de clubs
sportifs ça a été mis sur la table
dernièrement qui sont vérolées par
l'islamisme ont été fermées il n'y a pas
de volonté politique de s'attaquer aux
fondements de l'islamisme il n'y a pas
de moyens sur le terrain les forces de
l'ordre qui sont épuisées ont des heures
supplémentaires qui ne seront jamais
payé mais ils ne sont pas assez
nombreuses on est même parvenu au niveau
de nicolas sarkozy qui en avait supprimé
50 milles à l'époque donc par conséquent
oui je pense
win 10000
dix mille voyez où on en est je pense
que oui et au moment où non nos services
sont débordés par la surveillance des
fichiers est ce un christophe castaner
s'apprête peut-être à faire revenir 3
150 djihadistes les fichiers s'est rangé
vous vous souhaitez les expulser quand
on prend par exemple le bataclan en
novembre 2015 les trois terroristes du
bataclan étaient français est ce que
finalement ça permettrait de résoudre le
problème du terrorisme 3,3 pour être sur
ce cas de figure et sur les autres
affiches est étranger doit être expulsé
un fish est binational doit être déchu
de sa semaine de servir j'arrive et donc
et donc être expulsé un fichier s
français doit pouvoir subir l'article
411 4 du code de procédure pénale c'est
à dire être traduits devant les
tribunaux parce qu'il fait preuve
d'intelligence avec l'ennemi
voilà exactement ce qu'on appliquerait
ce qui répond aussi je crois madame à
votre question
si marine le pen était au pouvoir est ce
que nous pourrions faire reculer les
attentats en quoi finalement en quoi
puisqu'ils sont français parce que nous
appliquerions un certain nombre de
dispositions qui permettraient existé
l'oiseau ces gens nous de les enfermer
qui existent déjà qui te 424 qui n'est
pas utilisée on se demande bien pourquoi
ou de les éloigner de les excite les
sims 4 c en matière d'espionnage
il n'est pas intelligent mais la crise
est bien que ce soit les parlementaires
qui s'en saisisse
s'il faut ouvrir les deux savants que la
fiche s c'est pas une action judiciaire
bien sûr d'accord mais sans tirer des
enseignements à dire c'est de la
tuyauterie
voyez vous si on veut utiliser la fiche
est ce pour pouvoir surveiller un
certain nombre de personnes
c'est un outil intéressant mais si on
n'a pas la volonté politique une fois
qu'on a étudié ces profils et de se dire
que ces gens coûté ce type qui a eu 27
condamnations à 29 ans et qui n'étaient
pas français
qu'est ce qu'il fout encore sur le
territoire français moi je dis recettes
uniquement du bon sens quand on a été
condamné 27 fois est ce qu'on fout sur
les condamnations pour terrorisme
il avait la nationalité française et
bien il aurait dû être justement
traduits devant les tribunaux pour
intelligence avec l'ennemi puisqu'il
était fiche sc bien l'exemple dont je
vous parle et il avait 27 condamnations
pour lutter contre ce type de profil qui
est un délinquant un condamné pour
d'élèves pour délinquance parmi les
bières fraîches qualifiées elles luttent
contre l'esm radicalisation ben je vous
le dis je vous ai donné cet exemple on
ferme les mosquées salafistes ces
gens-là fréquente un certain nombre
d'endroits dans lesquelles la haine de
la france et est appelée répandues
chaque semaine dans les différents
endroits là dans les prisons jeu
radicalement aux rondeurs et dans les
prisons on isole les gens là on revient
sur le droit n'a les moyens d'isoler ces
gens là mais il faut s'en donner les
moyens je vous le dis c'est une question
de volonté et de moyens ya ni l'un ni
l'autre avec nous et je crois que les
français nous en font crédit nous avons
la volonté et les moyens le nombre de
places de prison que nous proposons est
largement supérieur à ce que le
gouvernement propose en fait le
gouvernement vernon reid le gouvernement
une vie vide and ocean avec une cuillère
à café perseigne
maintenant qu'on en sera là on pourra
pleurer faire des chansons et des
défilés anti terroriste en 30 ans à peu
près ce qu'il faut à nouveau légiférer
ou est ce que la loi actuelle est
suffisante pour vous il y a des lois
je vous ai parlé du code de procédure
pénale il ya des lois qui existent elles
peuvent être peut-être améliorer mais
elle existe utilisons les piles ya des
droits qu'il faut changer moi j'ai parlé
du droit du sol et je vais nous ont
raconté ça on a proposé à l'assemblée
nationale parce que nous sommes des gens
qui cherchons à trouver des solutions
nous avons proposé qu'on revienne sur le
droit du sol les républicains
c'est dans leur programme en robes de
monsieur wauquiez ne suis pas très
longtemps mais c'est dans leur propre
ils n'ont pas voté
ils sont partis ils n'ont pas voté ou
ils ont voté contre ceux qui étaient en
séance
donc je voulais une incohérence totale
il y a une incapacité dans cette classe
politique qui est aux affaires depuis 30
ans à s'armer de courage pour comprendre
que nous sommes en guerre c'est une
guerre que nous livrons même gérard
collomb le reconnaissait il y a des
quartiers qui sont vérolées la police
n'entre plus il faut soutenir nos forces
de l'ordre donné des moyens donner des
moyens aussi juridique aux forces de
l'ordre le principe de légitime défense
etc etc
nous avons un arsenal qui est disponible
il faut l'utiliser
vous dites il ya un arsenal qui est
disponible il y à des textes de loi qui
s'applique et il y à des textes qui
s'applique notamment pour les détenus
qui sont libérables et notamment des
détenus qui ont été condamnés pour
terrorisme et il y en a un certain
nombre qui s'apprête à sortir on nous en
parle régulièrement que faut-il faire
avec eux selon vous eh bien il faut un
suivi
c'est ce qui plaira à ceux des fruits
moi je n'ai pas confiant la ministre de
la justice
oui mais je n'ai pas confiance dans un
gouvernement parce que ce sont des
laxistes parce que lorsque je vois
madame belloubet nous faire voter la
semaine dernière un projet de la justice
dans lequel de tout sauf la prison est
privilégiée je n'ai pas confiance dans
ce gouvernement
je considère qu'il ne donne pas les
moyens qu'on les surveille je vous ai
donné un exemple très précis nous avons
beaucoup de richesses dans ce pays
d'ailleurs le débat sur le chiffre est
toujours ouvert et puis on s'apprête
peut-être en libérer d'autres mais en
faire venir d'autres qui ont combattu
pour le jihad
donc tant qu'on ne le focalisera pas nos
forces et qu'on ne mettra pas les moyens
en face nous aurons ce type de problème
donc il faut des moyens
il faut une volonté le gouvernement n'a
ni l'un ni l'autre y compris sur scène
the ce en particulier qui vont sortir de
prison est ce que vous défendez la
rétention de sûreté par exemple pour
s'est radicalisée qui doivent sortir à
la fin de l'année ou à la fin de l'année
prochaine je pense que c'est intéressant
à regarder
oui je pense que c'est intéressant de
regarder ça la rétention de sûreté
je pense que on peut se pencher là
dessus alors vous avez donc là beaucoup
parlé du jihadisme le grand spécialiste
du monde arabe gilles kepel qui suivant
les sites jihadistes qui sont encore en
fonction notamment en syrie explique
qu'en fait il a constaté que les
djihadistes se réjouissent du climat de
chaos qui a été créée dans le pays par
les gilet jaune
est-ce que cela vous alarmer ce qu'il y
a une responsabilité
à prendre en compte chez les jaunes on
va quand même pas faire porter au gilet
jaune sur le dos la responsabilité
juillet les sites des atrides jouissent
de l'assemblée sciences sociales dans
les seuls héritiers fable de la
situation de ce pays ce sont ceux qui
nous gouvernent les gilets jaunes alors
on les a décrédibilisé
on les a diabolisé maintenant on va
alors on va vous entendre on les a il
tient apparemment avalé par certains
sites jihadistes c'est ce que j ai
découvert simplement revenir sur terre
et se dire que ceux qui ont la
responsabilité
c'est ce gouvernement qui vient de
signer le pacte de marrakech qui va
permettre encore l'arrivée d'immigrés et
d'une immigration galopante dans notre
pays non les seules personnes
responsables de la situation de ce pays
ce sont ceux qui me regardent va
permettre l'arrivée d'une immigration
galopante comme vous savez très bien
qu'il est non contraignant cas mais ça
c'est le grand argument qu'on nous donne
eh bien c'est faux mais c'était
christophe oui on me les a traité
juridiquement non contraignant et
réaffirme le droit souverain des états
de définir leur politique mais grave
dans le national hors de réponse
pourquoi d'abord si c'était un type acte
bien gentil on n'en ferait pas un traité
qui passeraient devant le parlement est
ce qu'on ne mettrait pas en débat
pourquoi est ce que la part revenant
bien sûr sur l'immigration bien entendu
pourquoi est-ce que des états comme
israël
l'autriche les états unis qui sont
toutes deux grandes démocraties ont
elles ont ils refusé de signer ce pacte
avait aucune contrainte
non bien sûr la première phrase les
premières phrases de se pacser l'état
les états s'engagent à faciliter
l'émigration et ordonnée et régulier oui
il est un engagement là dedans et ceci
va devenir un droit opposable au final
parce que j'ai la liste des effectifs et
assurer l'accès aux migrants les servir
de base et perdre leur souveraineté sur
métal non laissez moi vous voulez y aura
des objectifs axe eu raison là aussi on
l'a où on l'a dit mais bien sûr assuré
l'économie grand des services de base
les minima sociaux le logement etc
éliminer toute forme de discrimination
c'est à dire pas de préférence nationale
on n'a plus droit d'en parler et puis
j'en ai un pour vous les médias en
dernier lieu et puis le mécanisme de
portabilité des droits de sécurité
sociale et le dernier
nation et le dernier qui pour vous et
ducret les médias et éduquer les médias
vous allez vous faire donc éduquer à
dire que l'immigration est quelque chose
de bien
eh bien vous n'aurez pas beaucoup
d'efforts à faire si je n'étais pas
serein d'inviter les noms je n'achète
pas les peurs vous savez ce pacte il
nous dégringole de haut
s'il n'y avait pas de problème pourquoi
est ce que il n'y aurait pas de débat
normaux ce que je pense c'est qu'en fait
ce pacte va permettre qu'il n'y ait plus
aucune distinction entre l'immigration
légale et l'immigration illégale
voilà ce qu'on veut faire voilà ce que
les gouvernements qui ont cette
idéologie immigrationniste emmanuel
macron là évidemment il la porte il est
soumis à cette idéologie vont faire de
notre pas leur image du maquereau il
s'est exprimé sur la question de
l'immigration n'en parlais tout à
l'heure à lors de l'annoncé du grand
débat il a dit il a évoqué les attentes
et les inquiétudes des français à ce
sujet donc c'est un sujet qui me prend
en main oui beaucoup d'efforts pour
faire des constats on attend autre chose
d'un président de la république on
attend qu'il protège les français nous a
montré qu'il n'était pas capable de les
protéger socialement il n'est pas
capable de les protéger face aux dangers
sécuritaires qui pèse sur nous là qu'on
nous dit je prends conscience de la
rendre une parenthèse monsieur venu pour
dire que depuis le début de l'année je
ne connais pas le chiffre exact mais il
ya beaucoup d'attenté qui ont été
déjoués vous le sait heureusement il
faut s'en féliciter
mais moi je vais vous donner d'autres
exemples
depuis l'arrivée des macros 9 août 2010
est à levallois perret l'auteur est
algérien le 1er octobre à la gare saint
charles de marseille
un clandestin tunisien tué deux jeunes
filles le 23 mars 2018 carcassonne
trèbes 5 morts cette affiche est-ce
franco-marocain le 12 mai 2018 à paris
un tchétchène ficher s
bon il en faut encore d'autres il en
faut beaucoup pour moi
mais heureusement il ya plus d'attentes
à des gens extraordinaires mais
heureusement
qu'est ce que ce serait je ferai ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'une migration dans
le débat la cause des élections
européennes nous la mettons depuis
toujours et pour toujours
tant que cette politique
immigrationniste sera suivie continuera
sera la même posera quand on quantité de
problèmes nous la mettrons toujours dans
le débat parce qu'elle fait partie
c'est trop peu
parce que ça vous arrange électoralement
aussi mais parce que c'est un problème
que vivent les français
mais c'est tout ça nous faisait ça ne
s'arrange pas électoralement puis bien
sûr que le communautarisme c'est un
problème bien sûr que des quartiers dans
lesquels on peut pas rentrer c'est notre
relation et bayal gala communautarisme
mais parce que l'immigration au niveau
où nous en sommes produits du
communautarisme c'est une évidence enfin
toutes les études l'expliquent
donc on peut avoir de chemin dans la vie
vous savez continuer à accueillir
on n'a que deux cent cinquante mille
immigrés légaux et 300 mille immigrés
illégaux par an sur le territoire
ces chiffres sont ceux de gérard collomb
et puis avoir la volonté de réduire au
maximum cette immigration illégale et
légal
c'est notre nation était ma question
réduire au minimum cette immigration
combien au minimum alors vous avez donné
au minimum pourquoi donner des chiffres
mais je me souviens de l'idéal ce serait
0 pour nous non mais y aura jamais de
l'immigration le zéro en tant que tel il
ya des étudiants il ya des gens qui
viennent et il ya des gens qui sont en
droit de venir
mais ce qu'on souhaite c'est la plus
basse immigration possible évidemment on
a vu trop se fracasser sur le mur des
chiffres des gens comme nicolas sarkozy
et leurs plafonds d'immigrés et caetera
et leurs quotas d'immigrés où je crois
que tout ça ne fonctionne pas il faut se
donner des objectifs une immigration la
plus proche de zéro mais ce que le
climat actuel cette crise sociale
économique politique
finalement ça va changer la nature de
l'élection européenne à venir est ce que
vous allez en faire un référendum pro ou
anti macron de fait les électeurs vont
se prononcer en faveur de deux chemins
politiques
celui qui portait depuis 18 mois par la
république en marche par emmanuel macron
et qui de mondialiste ultra libéraliste
et laxiste et puis la proposition
l'offre politique républicaine que nous
faisons c'est à dire dans laquelle les
nations sont libres indépendantes
coopèrent entre elles de façon libre
dans laquelle nous avons décidé de
protéger l'identité de la france ses
grands équilibres a je crois qu'elle
présente la république l'a installé
comme tel et je crois qu'entre les deux
n'y a pas grand chose qui existe comme
autre chemin de chemins existent
d'habitude nous et qui avait plus qu'une
politique à suivre celle qui a été menée
depuis 30 ans aujourd'hui on dit aux
français il ya une autre possibilité de
choix et cette possibilité d'autres
peuples l'ont choisi et en plus elle
fonctionne vous pensez vous allez sortir
vainqueur de ce duel
nous allons tout faire pour il ya une
autre liste celle de nicolas dupont
aignan crédité à 6 7% dans les sondages
il y a à peu près sur van linh est ce
que vous regrettez qu'il soit parti seul
bien sûr bien sûr j'aurais préféré que
nicolas du poignet en face le chemin
avec nous je note que à chaque fois que
les républicains perdre un point
dernièrement c'est nicolas dupont aignan
qui les récupèrent donc je pense que ça
peut être utile puisque nicolas dupont
aignan nous a dit nous nous retrouverons
pour siéger ensemble donc entré dans le
groupe par le 31e nicolas dupont aignan
indiqué donc évidemment s'il a des
députés pour la première fois élu sous
ses couleurs
eh bien nous les accueillerons volonté
de travailler à la constitution de ce
groupe avec qui et avec quel outil nous
avons pas mal d'alliés aujourd'hui je
pense que nous avons un nouvel allié
espagnol vous avez pu vous en rendre
compte dernièrement nous avons des
alliés dans tous les pays en allemagne
en autriche en italie évidemment dans
tous les pays d'europe aujourd'hui ce
qui nous amène à dire que non seulement
nous ne sommes plus seuls
mais que la majorité peu basse et vous
avez divisés et sous ces partis sont
divisés un seul exemple sur
l'immigration et la demande est haï
demande par exemple une plus grande vous
êtes d'accord une plus grande solidarité
européenne pour accueillir notamment les
réfugiés ne vous agrée par la hongrie
dit non ne vous inquiète c'est un exode
division nous avons une plateforme qui
va nommer là sur ce point l'armée nous
inquiétez pas nous avons une plateforme
qui est présenté dans laquelle les pays
diront ce sur quoi ils s'entendent nos
partenaires ce sur quoi ils s'entendent
pour le reste les nations sont libres et
indépendants quand certains de vos
alliés dirige des pays où l'état de
droit est mis en difficulté c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire
vous pensez à quoi je pense à la hongrie
par exemple eh bien moi je vais vous
dire je ne donne pas de leçons à partir
du moment où en france je ne pouvais
tirer des conclusions des combats rudes
et elle n'est pas là non mais écoutez
moi je donne pas de leçon aux et à
partir du moment où dans mon propre pays
on n'a pas la proportionnelle on muselle
l'opposition ont fait reculer encore les
droits des députés à l'assemblée
nationale
alors je ne donne pas de leçon on peut
payer de comparer les vous parlez des
paroles aussi que si hongrie à la france
alloue par les démocraties
je parle des entorses au droit les
tables et les locales lesquelles entorse
écoutez maintenant maîtresse mise en
cause la presse met en cause doivent au
fisc et mis sous tutelle
je pense que ce qui se passe en france
devraient nous interroger je pense que
les biens sur les collusions entre la
justice un certain nombre de facteurs
politiques a je pense qu'on dévie avec
emmanuel macron de plus en plus non
seulement d'un état de droit on
s'éloigne de ce que peut être la
démocratie bon attendez vous avez pas
vous allez parler de dictature non
s'éloigne de ce que peut être la
démocratie quand il n'y a pas la
proportionnelle dans un pays quand
personne ne peut être représenté quand
on empêche au principal parti laissez
moi quand on empêche au principal parti
d'opposition d'avoir une banque on nous
a empêchés pendant 6 à 8 mois d'avoir
accès au crédit bancaire principal parti
d'opposition ont alors réalisé alors nos
noms et la banque pour la démocratie on
en est où la banque pour la démocratie
on en est où
quand on quand on court après un parti
politique aux conditions de prêt à
mettre un genou à terre non mais manque
non non
l'état peut avoir et vous savez très
bien pu avoir une influence sur un
certain nombre de banques et la banque
de la démocratie de ré permet cette
année en france et non assumée par la
crise a été enterré non quand on essaye
de faire taire l'opposition par d'autres
voies que les urnes alors on s'éloigne
de la démocratie en europe il pourrait y
avoir des alliances de circonstance sur
certains votes sur certains textes avec
la france 1 soumise par exemple écouter
nous avons déjà voté à l'assemblée
nationale
des propositions d'un france insoumises
du ps des républicains nous ne sommes
pas des gens secteur ce qui apporte ce
n'est pas l'émetteur c'est le message
d'accord il pourrait y avoir une
alliance vous pensez en france non non
non du tout là vous savez le problème de
la france un souci c'est qu'ils en
prennent avec l'immigration
ils veulent qu'ils sont favorables à
l'accueil en toutes circonstances
bon bah ça nous c'est pas un mot
rapidement sur votre tête de liste vous
nous confirmer que ça sera jordan dare
mais là je ne vous confirme pas c'est
vrai il ne pèse que vous confirmera sa
donc en attendant on attendra qu'elles
reviennent nous voir alors je voulais
vous demander quand même pour conclure
mais s'agissant vous sur les organes
parlons sur la loge à la fusion ladite
aurait plus le temps la question de
l'outre-mer seront présents travers un
jour à leur auditoire
est ce que vous êtes pour la pma pour
toutes
alors moi je suis pas trop favorable à
ça pour des raisons qui font que je
pense que la capacité à connaître c'est
son ascendance est importante et que ça
ne peut pas se réduire un choix d'adulte
qui veulent un enfant c'est pas la
question de la parentalité
un couple homo peut très bien
c'est un enfant et aux clients qualiac a
notamment je connais votre priorité vous
avez été logées défendues le mariage et
vous dire ni bien sûr l'or est donc je
pense que c'est pas la question de la
parentèle vient d être con mais je viens
mercato l'égalité pendant longtemps nous
a dit il faut avoir accès à ses origines
et bien moi je crois que oui il faut
pouvoir voir accession c'est la fin de
cette émission merci
sébastien chenu merci mesdames d'avoir
été avec nous et merci d'avoir suivi
cette émission la prochaine fois on
accueillera donc en ce sens en 2019
qu'on a connu à marine le pen elle sera
là ce jour là merci en tous les cas vous
l'avait remplacé merci à tous passer
d'excellentes fêtes puisque on se
retrouvera maintenant l'année prochaine